what's up guys I'm Leon I'm John
together we are the lean machines and
today we're down at the Olympic Park
we're going to be checking out the
aquatics in there today getting some
lunch and we're going to slide down that
I don't know what it is but it looks fun
let's go swimming and me aren't the best
of friends
I like to call yeah I like the theory of
swimming more than I actually do it it's
the kind of I just get out of breath so
easy I can't do all the head under each
side breathing I need to get better of
that I don't think about I had like two
years where I was learning properly to
front crawl because it just looked good
and I thought about doing a triathlon
and then I had a whole new appreciation
for how hard swimming actually is let's
go and get chains and get jumping first
things first look at your lifestyle
right now and figure out how much time
you can actually give to being healthier
whether it means you're going for a walk
or whether it means you can have four or
five sessions in the gym a week whatever
time you've got and how much you
actually want to achieve when it comes
to being healthier and what your goal is
yeah I'm from a mental aspect I do
exactly the same thing ask yourself in
your life what makes you happy and what
makes you feel unhappy and can you kind
of switch that balance there's more the
happy stuff in there and that's to be
unhappy one of the most happy times for
me is actually being able to live my
life away from social media with my now
wife and we've hanging out with John and
his partner and all my friends and I
think that's where all the magic is a
negative four is five times more
powerful than the positive four so it's
so easy to grab one negative four and
hold on to it you have to replace that
obviously with five positive ones so you
have to constantly reinforce the
positive to kind of overshadow those and
keep yourself happy really so we've been
having a look around and obviously we've
never been here before let's use this
opportunity awesome surroundings it's
kind of a workout and have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
so we've just been for some lunch but
the weather's so good that we thought
we'd come outside and sit on the bank
which is a massive rarity here in the UK
we've had a full-on day so far we went
swimming yeah we had a workout and now
we've just had our lunch which is a
really important time I think we should
talk nutrition eating well is obviously
kind of getting good nutrition in your
life to support your body moving better
it's just allowing people to be more
active it doesn't matter if you're in
the gym doesn't matter if you're rowing
if you're climbing if you're doing yoga
as long as you're being active I'm
feeling healthier I'm feeling awesome
it's the encompass of all of them yeah
it's the mindset it's the it's the
Golden Nugget that ties everything
together as long as you've got a good
relationship with food you've got a good
diet or protocol in place that makes you
feel happy and it doesn't restrain you
or hold you back so much if you restrict
yourself and having something it
instantly puts barriers up if I was to
go crazy it'd be jaffa cakes really
whole pack of them whole pack the reason
we did the book was really because there
was nothing out there like it and it was
a massive hole like you can have the
most amazing body in the world but if
you're unhappy at the end of the day
then it means nothing yeah so the book
does have the training workout it has
the nutritional stuff it has the recipes
which is absolutely brilliant but the
biggest first section of the book is all
about mindfulness and being happy how to
be more positive and if you've got that
positivity nailed you're going to
absolutely fly when it comes to the
aesthetic results my life motto is all
about having fun it's we don't stop
playing because we grow old we grow old
because we stop playing that's beautiful
pa China Japan that Peter Pan is and
mine is live for the day enjoy and make
the most of every single moment because
you're not going to get it back
[Music]
[Applause]
we're now at the top of the awesome
Mattel orbit where 18 meters right now
the tallest sculptor in the UK and it
has a beautiful panoramic view of the
city 20 miles you can see on a clear day
I didn't realize just how far you could
see it mega we're now going to ride the
slow which starts at 76 meters and rumor
has it we're going to be going about 50
miles an hour I'm so down for that I'm
very excited
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah hahaha
that was so much fun there's that one
corner at the start that just caught me
off guard if you were ever down this way
totally recommending it was a lot of fun
you get to see a panoramic view of the
city as well it was just awesome and it
gets you out of the house and there you
have it thanks so much for hanging out
with us today it was an awesome day if
you want to see more videos like this
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
glamour UK if you want to find us
whittling machines all of our links are
in the description box below see that
guy